[Music] I can't believe that
these two are my soul mate that God told me about.
There are over 100 people that you are destined to meet in high school.
Staff: It seems
like I fell in love with your interpretation at first sight, so I made it out
safely.  I don't like you at all.
I fell in love with you at first sight because of your mental state. I'm
dating either of us. For the
first time in my life, a girl confessed to me. I'm so
happy. I seriously
can't choose this is my soulmate.  It's
ok to have a student romance that takes you to the limit of time. I'll give it my all to make you happier than anyone else, so I
'll accept it. If God gives it to me, I don't know what it's
like for us.
[Music] We
were born right now.  I'm the
happiest